Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two. David, P..
Now, many of you will be familiar with today's
caller. Today's caller is the San Antonio troll.
The San Antonio troll is known to me and
probably to some of you for calling in
and delivering blistering criticism
directed at me for things I never said.
And that's exactly what he does today.
Typical of the San Antonio troll.
Speaker 7: Man, I watched your
coverage to the State of the Union, and
I just can't you progressives are the most out
of touch people on this freaking planet, OK? And
what's funny is most of y'all are just hundreds,
you know, who live in nice neighborhoods,
scattered neighborhoods and gated neighborhoods.
You don't really see, I thought Biden did a good
job. I think he's done a good job so far.
Speaker 1: That's fine. That's that's
totally respectable, OK?
Speaker 7: And I think
his state of the Union is great. And I am
absolutely prepared to vote for a Democrat
in 2024.
Speaker 1: I don't know if the
San Antonio drawl is serious about that, but OK.
Speaker 7: I mean, who's going to get some of
the scientists come on? Who are we kidding here?
Having said all that? You complain about Biden,
one of bring energy production back to the United
States, whereas you don't see that it hurts the
working, these gas prices hurt the average person.
Speaker 1: Now this is where the troll goes off
the rails. I did not criticize Joe Biden wanting
to bring energy production domestically. To be
honest, I don't even know if Joe Biden mentioned
that what I spoke about was Joe Biden offhandedly
saying, We're going to build and manufacture
everything here in the U.S. and buy American.
And as I've said before, when Donald Trump
has said things like this, as I said before,
when Barack Obama said things like this,
the kind of casual nature with which elected
officials say this ignores the reality that
our economy is based on not making stuff here.
We have decided implicitly through our decisions
about trade and regulation over the last 20 to
30 years that we prefer as a country, I'm
not saying you or I prefer it, but we prefer
as a country to have lower prices on stuff and
to make it abroad. And so when politicians,
they all do it, they say, we're going to bring
everybody, we're going to make everything here.
It could take decades or longer to reconstruct the
supply chains domestically to do that number one
and number two, everything would get way more
expensive. So when the San Antonio Patrol says
I was against Biden doing domestic energy, but
I don't remember Biden even talking about that.
I was talking about manufacturing
domestically, not gas, not gas. So again, troll
criticize someone who said it. It wasn't me.
Speaker 7: We don't have a bottomless bank
account like you do in other elites where
you can just categorize everywhere you
go. So we feel it at the pump and we are.
Speaker 1: I've been I've been all over the
gas price thing and I've been saying this is not
15 cents per gallon. We're talking about impactful
amounts of money now. So I don't know. This guy
must have me confused with someone else. Maybe
Alex Jones was saying this stuff. I don't know
Speaker 7: the majority vote, and this is why he's
Biden has to do this or he's definitely going to
lose. And I just don't see that. You see it. Oh,
we need to be complete green energy because
you drive a car that's know not all of us
could afford that, dude. You have to
see it from the poor man's perspective.
Speaker 1: I genuinely don't know what he's
talking about. I did. I have. I don't know what
commentary of mine. This is even a reference to
Speaker 7: even the poor man, just the working
class. And it's something I think you've
lived in this, you know, wealthy, liberal,
you know, wealthy neoliberal bubble for so long.
Speaker 1: Oh, give me a break, dude. Yeah, go go.
Talk to someone who said this stuff. So there's
the San Antonio drawl. I'm I am still holding out
hope that someday, someday, I believe it will
happen. The San Antonio trial will call. And
actually address something I've said, as opposed
to something he attributes to me that I've never
actually talked about. A Florida senator, Rick
Scott's tax plan is under fire and it should be,
and we're going to talk about it on today's bonus
show. A few months ago, a couple of months ago,
I told you about the first successful
pig heart transplant into a human.
Sadly, the recipient, an American man, has died,
and we're going to talk about what this means
for this particular medical technology. What
happened? It is sad, but we're going to follow
up on the story, and the final remaining American
mask mandate is in Hawaii, and that will be lifted
in 16 days on March 26. We will talk about
now with state mandates are all going away,
which municipalities are maintaining masking
requirements, if any. And we'll talk about masks,
all of those. Or, as Marjorie Taylor Greene likes
to say, we will talk about mask on the bonus show,
all of those stories and more. I will be joined by
producer Pat on the bonus show. You can sign up at
join Packman dot com. It is a great place to
sign up. I believe the normal membership prices
are perfect, but you can get a discount using the
coupon code. Wow. 22. Now, just remember you will
be adversarial to Alex Jones if you sign up as a
member. Alex Jones doesn't like the bonus show.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money and everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: He's against it. I am very much for the
bonus. Sign up at Join Pacman dot com.
Unidentified: I'll see you back.